a circle is centered on point b we see
that right over there that's the center
of this big blue circle points a c and d
lie on its circumference we see that
points a c and d lies circumference
if angle abc so a b c so that's this
central angle right over here measures
132 degrees all right so this is 132
degrees what does angle adc measure a
d c so let's think about how these are
related a b c is a central angle a d c
is an inscribed angle and they intercept
the same arc the arc a c they both
intercept this arc right over here
and we know from the inscribed angle
theorem that an inscribed angle that
intercepts the same arc as a central
angle is going to have half the angle
measure and you could even it even looks
that way right over here so if abc if
the central angle is 132 degrees then
the inscribed angle that intercepts the
same arc is going to be half of that so
half of 132 degrees
is what it is 66 degrees
we can check our answer and we got it
right